hey guys mkbhd here today we're going to
be taking a look at the best apps in the
chrome web store so i guess this is for
the chrome users who watch these videos
but if you haven't already discovered it
i did a video on the new layout of the
chrome web store and it looks pretty
spiffy so i figured i'd highlight the
best apps available in it all these are
free by the way this
this is this is my 401st youtube video
so if we could get 401 likes on this
video that would be awesome either way
let's go ahead and dive right into this
the first app is called weather bite and
it's this really clean minimalist classy
looking weather app i just use it when i
want to get a little bit information
real quick like the temperature or
whether or not i need a jacket for the
day but if you take a look at the
interface you'll notice it's really good
looking i highly recommend it just
because for those of you who like the
minimalist style like me it really does
look good and matches up with the chrome
web browser it gives you all the
information you need to know you can
switch between cities real quick has
these nice simple icons uh everything
about it is nicely laid out and it looks
good so i highly recommend this one it's
called weatherbyte the next one's called
tweetdeck yeah tweetdeck for chrome you
might have seen my earlier mkbhd video
where i just highlighted just that app
tweetdeck for chrome looks really good
and it's not quite as powerful as the
desktop app because you can't really get
in real time notifications streaming or
you can't really change the colors but
you do get that twitter facebook and
foursquare integration all your social
media in one place so if you don't
really like going to the individual
websites you'll definitely like
tweetdeck and uh it's nice to have that
sync availability so uh if you sign into
tweetdeck on multiple platforms it all
syncs together nicely good stuff next on
this list try audio tool i'm not going
to claim i know how to make music in any
way but this app kind of makes me
try pretty unique one that's yet again
also free is called webcam toy it might
remind you of photo booth for max
because of all the crazy effects it
gives you but this one is totally
web-based anyone with a webcam can now
take advantage of these awesome myspace
photo effects but honestly it's got this
snazzy pink color scheme it has a whole
ton of photo effects to give you guys
the ability to take all these different
types of pictures uh you have the
ability to set a countdown timer so you
can have both hands off the computer
when it sets the shutter and you can
fool all your myspace friends into
thinking you have a mac even if you
don't because you have chrome and webcam
toy
wait
what's what's my space alright here's a
cool one it's called good food makes me
want to cook all these fancy fancy
recipes because it presents them in such
a nice clean organized manner taking a
look at the layout they give you a nice
picture of the food you're about to cook
they even give you an estimated time it
takes to prepare the dish so you know
how long it takes to make the food
you're about to start making
which i i multiply by about three
because i have no idea what i'm doing
all right let me introduce you to the
independent it's actually an extension
for a uk newspaper that allows you to
take advantage of all the recent
headlines and view them in one nice
layout in the corner of your web browser
it's not an application but there's
actually an extension that is just in
the corner so you can tap that button
and the more you tap that the more
headlines you get and it looks really
good and i highly recommend it so if you
guys have chrome and you live in the uk
and you read the independent you'll
definitely like this one
yeah last but not least is wunderlist i
discovered this app a couple of days ago
and it just took over my life i used
google tasks to organize my life and
remember everything when i discovered
wunderlist it took over and now i use
that to remember everything wunderlist
is a really nicely laid out and pretty
well customizable tasks list managing
application so you can use this to set
you know homework or tasks you need to
do or change the background color from
wood to granite whatever you want to do
uh i honestly was really excited for
this because there's an android app
there's an ios app there's an os 10 app
there's a windows desktop app and now
there's the chrome app so it's basically
everywhere in my life that i needed to
be and uh that's pretty awesome so check
it out all these apps are in the chrome
web store and their links are down in
the description pointing at the crotch
but yeah it's there trust me now i
didn't include any games on this list uh
that's not because they're paid they're
actually all mostly free but i just
didn't want you guys to end up like i
did when i first discovered these games
no but seriously there are a lot of
great games in the chrome web store that
didn't make this list so if you check
out the new chrome web store you guys
can view all the apps and all the games
that i haven't showed you guys in this
video so enjoy those so there you go
thanks for watching this video and uh be
sure to subscribe if you haven't already
and i'll talk to you guys late like
later
later later
g'day mate
you